donc comme canal c'est les nuls
on va vous faire une interview nul en l1
et le graphisme ne passera pas non mais
là il s'agit là dessus pas mal et c'est
d'ailleurs
pierre lescure êtes prêts est ce que
vous préférez staline ou hitler staline
a dérivé il est devenu l'un des pires
tyrans et il a fait un mal abominable et
des millions de gens mais au départ il
s'agissait d'aider l'ensemble de la
population pauvre use it passe en
mémoire de votre père non non non aux
salines un peu mieux un peu moins mal
ouais parce qu'il a tué plus de gens qui
s'étaient pas gênés side
ouais il n'avait pas décréter que c'est
quand on envoie les gens en sibérie
enfin mon nom mais il n'avait pas
décréter qu'une race c'est une classe
lui
mais pourquoi tu mets pas ma ou danton
quiz on boit le mettrais je le garde
profil et le solaire d'accord vous
partez trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
vous partez avec qui charles biétry
guillaume durand michel toulouse jeanne
un mannequin ouais toulouse quand même
des qualités toulouse parce qu'il a il a
une imagination que quelque chose a
perverti sans doute dans son application
mais ils continuent d'avoir une
imagination qui va être intéressante et
réjouissante dans ce voyage ce fameux
voyage qui dure trois ans quand même
faut bien l'avouer si c'est pour écouter
les histoires de durant pendant pendant
trois révolutions qui prime pas de
billetterie pour apam commenter les
matchs en direct voilà d'accord et je
vous préférez faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide ou un mec très beau une
fille très laide
ah ouais vous le pape et des détours
j'ai tellement de copains au mot un que
je pense que si j'étais un soupçon d'
homo ça se saurait moi je le serai ouais
ça se sait demandez lui ce que vous
préféreriez
vous réincarner en patrick le lay le
patron de tf1 marc tessier le patron de
france télévisions où nicolas de
tavernost le patron de m6 eh ben je vais
vous dire un truc les way patrick le lay
parce que ce qui m'est pas défendable
dans votre bouquin sur lui la paix c'est
pas une vraie détestation votre amour à
ce qu'on croyait il vous vous étonne
quand même y méthode parce qu'il fait
des trucs que je suis incapable de fait
qui merite deux claques et puis surtout
un type qui vers 40 ans alors qu'il a
construit des autoroutes les grands
bâtiments des plateformes de de pétrole
au large de l'océan
oui lui dit francis lui dit patrick up
la télé ici mais après on peut discuter
plein de détails plein de manière plate
forme mais sur le fond quel boulot un
magnifique
est ce que vous savez vous lécher la
langue ah non essayez là essaye de te
lécher la main possible mais si tu veux
pas possible de lécher la langue est ce
que tu peux regarder les yeux
si vous aviez un perroquet oui est ce
que vous le prendriez comme phrase qui
devrait répéter comme ça toute la
journée
moi ne fallait pas fermer le gaz tu as
pensé à la capote ou coco arrête là coco
tu affirmes et le gaz 1 parce que j'ai
une famille maintenant faut que je pense
à tout le monde d'accord est-ce que vous
accepteriez de mourir comme ça là
maintenant s'ils savaient déjà qu'il ya
peu de chances à priori 6 sv éradiquer
pour toujours la pauvreté sur la terre
non non parce que c'est une question
vous êtes là jésus-christ oeuvre non à
la je perds mais ça vous le saviez vous
dans tes fiches vous parle c'est trop
facile de dire un mot oui je suis prêt à
mourir tout de suite vous savez bien que
tu essaies anticipées possibles si
c'était possible je le ferai alors quand
le mec dit oui on le faire
est-ce que vous préféreriez mourir alors
attention c'est très grave comme otis
redding dans un crash d'avion comme john
lennon abattu comme janis joplin dans
une overdose ou comme le mec des 6-10 y
est étouffé par son vomi évidemment atys
reding ouais parker ce qu'on fait c'est
bien parti mais qui leur sert de centre
genèse je continue à le rendre beaucoup
d'avions jusqu'à fin contrairement à
kenny g patelin voilà est-ce que vous
aimeriez avoir un nez supplémentaires
doivent être un peu court
oui là un vol supplémentaire
attention un doigt supplémentaire ou un
sexe supplémentaires un doigt un doigt
toi qui prends la porte envers les deux
en même temps
et il parle plus qu'avec jules dassin il
met pas la main sur la cuisse a joué
aussi
gildas il mettait la main sur la cuisse
oui pour pas que tu parles
j'ai parfois souvent je pense qu'il dit
vrai pourquoi ils fêtaient la main sur
là parce que c'était pas le moment parce
qu'il s'était pas et maintenant qu'il
avait envie que je parle parce qu'il
avait son truc qui voulaient pas perdre
le fil et puis et puis la connerie c'est
bien beau mais lui voulait il voulait
déroulé sont câblés
et voilà c'est gentil ce qu'ils disent
lescure surtout à lens en bouquin oui
c'est une phrase en même temps bah oui
mais bon beaucoup de phrases qui sont
pas gentils à l'époque de l'acharnement
des guignols à mon endroit il m'avait
fait
passer des petits messages pour me dire
me faire dire qu'il n'était pas d'accord
et j'avais trouvé ça très gentil de la
part de pierre ce qui n'était pas obligé
de 20 de faire ça quoi
pierre quel est à votre avis le sport le
plus con le fist fucking meziche étoiles
de curling masculin
histoire de désir je pose de